il est 19h45 et bienvenue ten touche pas
à
mot merci les chéis merci d'être là euh
vous avez vu je voudrais juste vous
montrer cette image euh avec nos amis de
la nupesse Gilles oh tes potes euh pas
mes amis mais si si c'est tes amis vous
avez tous vu cette image des députés
dans la rue mathde Panau et Sandrine
Rousseau qui ont décidé de dormir sous
destentees avec des SDF mais il fallait
pas qu'elles aient trop faim donc elles
ont été mangé dans une brasserie du 7e
arrondissement juste avant bon eux alors
là bon bah voilà une fois de plus hein
les mythos de sorties regardez ça ça
normalement ça voilà ça ça résume tout
je vous le dis ça voilà cet extrait là
résume tout toute la super
ch pas la vieille politique des années
80 ils sont restés bloqués làdans non
mais sans rigoler mati Panau croyait
qu'on allait tomber dedans le
panneau
envoyé pour qui pour tous pour qui pour
tous pour quand tout de suite pourand
tout suite pourand tout suite Macron
arrête ton Bartin
réquisition la honte la hon à ce pouvoir
qui laisse les G CR sur le trottoir mais
quelle bande
de dans une tente la tente est sous une
grand mais quelle bande de quelle bande
de c'est vraiment des Gug
SR en
plus c'est dégueulasse parce que tu peux
taper sur Macron si ça te plaît pas mais
d'aller là et chanter rigoler parce
qu'il rigolent et le froid c'est pas une
nuit le froid c'est c'est de novembre à
avril c'est pas une seule nuit donc il
alleer comme ça rigoler après le resto
on a chanté on a bu on va enfin on a bu
a PR
un même les sansr
son Prem à dire qu'on instrumentalise
deses choses
isend il ve les défendre ce guignol
défendre
guignol si c'est tes amis arê un peu tu
les défends à chaque fois il est 19h48
tu m'nerves
déjà arrête un peu tu guign
avec tu cisvie
d'entendre gu gu on
ACI d' 20
ans les
équipes on fait plein des trucs comme ça
où on nous emmenait alors une fois à
côté d'un pauvre une fois à côté d'un
SDF une fois à côté d'un et il fallait
que ça fasse la blague et on Ron que
c'est n'importe quoi c'est ils sont
restés bloqués à cette périod là puis
alors ils sont fait pincer parce qu'ils
étaient 2 heur avant dans un
rest arrê de vouloir faire des mythos
tout ce on crame tout allez alors on va
voir la défense de leur amis et ne dites
pas que ça sont pas vos amis parce que
on sait très bien ce sont V amis c'est
pas mes amis maisux plus
tuis j'is jamais parlé donc c'est pas
mes amis vas-y bah vas-y en fait vous
détournez totalement le sujet fait un
coup de il sont allés à la demande de
droit au logement et de Monsieur héros
ils sont allés là-bas ce sont les seuls
qui se sont déplacés c'est lui qui était
à l'initiative il aura dit bah si vous
voulez parler de nous venez et ils ont
passé du temps avec eux ils ont laissé
le matériel après pour les sans abriis
ils ont ils ont bien fait attention de
pas occuper des tentes qui aurait pu
mettre des gens dehors gu cont G
on hisire restant du 7 ou dans le
restaurant ch du 7e ils ont invité des
sans ABR non mais ils ont invité des
sans abris dans le restaurant chic du
mais peuter il il veent
la contreiss parler g là là où moi je
comprends tout à fait le le patron du
droit au logement qui appelle des
politiques à venir mais est-ce que eux
sont besoin de simuler et de faire un
sagré sous une tente qu VI non mais ils
peuvent venir ils peuvent venir et
accompagner le droit au logement qui est
une association formidable le DAL c'est
une association formidable ils peuvent
venir les accompagner sans faire un
simulac en se mettant les G com à réagir
sur les réseau ilfend
toujourséfend extraordinaire c'est que
tu es obligé de nous faire le soustitre
de la vraie histoire c'est bien la
preuve que leur communication elle est
total
communation g je vais te dire alors là
tu vois encore une fois chaque jour tu
vas encore plus loin dans dans vraiment
il va il va il va dans l' non mais il
vient de nous dire à nous qu'on a menti
alors que c'est eux qui se sont fait
cramer la main dans le pot de confiture
et lui il vient nous dire à nous que
c'est nous qui avons
menti Mo je défend toujours mes amis
mais quand quand mes amis sont
indéfendables je ferme ma gueule m
amis logement a dit on va on va boire
des cafés là-bas c'est le café qui est à
côté c'est un desessens ce qu'ils ont
fait ils aura dû inviter même les
sansabr dans dans le restaurant tiens au
lie de faire les guignoles dans une
tente au dessus d'une autre tente non
mais écoute-moi bien Guignol suorté
guign quand même
incroable guignol am guignol a dit face
caméraelle avait suivi la conférence de
presse dans une dans une tente avec les
sans ABR alors qu'elle était là en train
de regarder dans la brasserie
exuse rend de la B pierre la bierre
faisait exactement le contraire vraiment
il dormait vraiment
pas se qui
ontépu ils ont
instrumentalisé ils ont essayé de faire
un coup politique céit le soir de la
loocution Macron et donc de faire d'une
pierre de coup en parlant de façon
annexe du droit au logement et en fait
pour essayer de taper le plus sur Macron
c'était pas du tout le
vrai
pléquiless insultant pour les gens qui
pas de logement et pour les gens qui
dorment dehors tu dois pas faire ça
quand toi fa les choses ils sont à
l'Assemblée faites les choses ATT Macron
attaqué monsieur le Président sur des
trucs qu'il a dit il a dit qu'il y aura
plus de SDF en 2017 il a dit il s'est
engagé il s'est engagé qu' aura plus SD
y a toujours des SDF tu peux l'attaquer
là-dessus comme tous les présidents tu
peux l'attaquer là-dessus mais insulter
les gens c'est comme les gens qui
j'étais une journée de travail je suis
monté derrière un camion débur pendant
une heure pour faire des photos insultez
pas les gens laissez les gens
tranquilles et faites les les gens pour
qu'ils sortent de la rue faites les
choses pour qu'ils sortent de la rue pas
restaurant le restaurant c'est le se fin
c'est très bon d'ailleurs c'est le
restaurant si boulvard Saint-Germain
dans 7 Paris les les députés ont pu
trouver du foie gras de canard des
escargots de Bourgogne des huîres du
bœuf de landouillettes mais aussi des
crêpes des mousses et des fondants au
chocolat ils aurit mieux fait les offrir
au sansabriis puis que c'est ce sont des
guignoles on peut voir les photos de gu
plus en faisant ça en faisant cette
vidéo en plus il confisque le vrai sujet
qu'en fait on parle deux et on parle pas
du problème en fait on parle pas de la
précarité on parle pas des sansabris
c'est exactement ce que dirait et en
plus mathle Panou qui chante là dans la
tente elle prend même pas le temps
d'enlever son
airp détail tout dire mépris absolu je
suis là je fais le sourire je fais la
chanson je fais la blague là comme ça
mais bon en j'ai pas que ça à [__] non
plus quand même donc en fait je vais
vite dégager et je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse moi je on peut tous aller
passer une nuit avec un SDF tous aant
qu'on est même dans le public on peut
rester une nuit on le fait quand vous
voulez il demande la réquisition des
logements ilte plainte contre le
gouvernement précédent pour
action il on jamais rien fait AR
defendre Fall pas dire qu'il all passer
une nuit avec pas mes amis et
d'autortable c'est les seuls qui ont
répondu à l'appel de droit au logement
je suis désolé au logement c'est pas mes
amis mais c'est pas mes amis je les
connais
pas fa pas des hér' fais pas des hér
fais pas des hér fais pas des héros
parce qu'ils ont répondu à un appel pour
moi aussi demain si tu veux je te le dis
là tous aant qu'on est dans le public
all mais moi je peux dormir de jours
dans la rue mais je peux pas DMIR Mo
c'est c'est démago vous dites toujours
que moi je suis démago mais là c'est le
sommet de la
démagogie c'est H qui l'a demandé conis
h il est de quel bord il est il est
parti c'est normal que voilà il a fait
exprè de le faire le soir où il y avait
Emmanuel Macron arrête de dire des
conneries tu es vraiment é es aussi naïf
qu'avec ta meuf
excuse-moia gratuite merci mais c'est
vrai c'est insupportable la naïveté du
gars arrête un peu tu vois bien son lae
to et toi tu plonges les de piedsans je
plonge pas les deux pieds dans j'essaie
d'expliquer que
tu peux être de GAE comme je suis être
juste ver toujours il veut bien faire
voir de C
gens je su désolé mais je pe pas encore
un mot au moins ça fait un peu parler de
la situation il y a quand même de fois
plus de
auour pour moi non c'est pas mes amis du
tout mais pour moi c'est pas parce que
tu vas au restaurant avant que tu peux
pas défendre les gens qui sont
sont G on
l'arentendp deentends vos aruments je
trouve que vous êtes unu dans écoutei
écoute-moi écoute-moi parce que là
Florent
p
je vais te dire un truc mon chéri moi
siil avent invité tous les SDF qui é
làbas vous allez aller au restaurant
avec nous et après on va vous ramener là
j'aurais dit oui mais là c'est
inadmissibleous on aime bien aider les
gens et pourtant on a aussi des
situations rien à voir pas làbas c'est
comme si comme si c'est comme si tuar j
c'est comme si tu arriv en plein Ramadan
avec un sandwich au
jambon restaurant ce
soir des G qui même
pas a plein d'actions sincères que tu
peux faire tuas pas besoin de faire le
guignol camé de télévision soir et en
all en allant
dîner
di ave les sansr c'est totalement
fauxsong ce n pour
idéaluse rigol ou tu la pas sont que
dans la que
du Ren à [__] des G
ou savait déjà il demande tout le temps
l'oire des rquisition ils les ont pas
les
réquin mon ami qui me dit j'aiécris pour
être aidé à tout le monde à l'Assemblé
nationale les seuls qui n'ont jamais
répondu c'est la France insoumise c'est
juste un coup de com tiens les amis Gill
verneis une fois de
plus
inadmissible a des associations qui
travaillent il y a des bénévoles end
ouais mais j'aime bien TR entendre
surtout répondre à ton pote non en fait
non mais j'ai dit moi je trouve que
c'est évidemment une instrumentalisation
absolument Abe et IGN je pense que c'est
la non mais Gill en fait Gill il est
voilà il a beaucoup de cœur il est dans
l'humanité cette
photo on a l'imession c'est une campagne
pour une tente Quecha pour descathelons
et qu'elles sont juste là pour faire une
belle photo en fait pour mettre sur leur
poste insta et pour dire vous avez vu
come on est bien guignol pas que ça
laque aprs la mauaise
politique et après ils en on rien à
[__] ils se lavent les mains ils
disent nous on est du on est dans le
camp du bien et on fait du alors que les
aut du mal à la potique mal la polique
pour moi juste pour les caméras ils sont
là non moi c'est gênant moi je vois ça
j'ai des frissons de gên voilà bravo tu
sais à chaque fois résum bien tu je te
dis les frons de
G c'est pas une expérience quand il est
bah exactement voilà c'est ça que je
c'est ça que je tu vois dit une pH en
une phrase elle t' calmé c'est pas une
expérience c'est pas un jeu c'est pas la
parole mais sin fait 2 he que tuas la
parole B répond lui elle va te recalmer
mais c'est pas vous vivez pour les
caméras eux ils vivent ils vivent ils
vivent pour rétblir sont pas s
amis le trouver un logement on s'en fout
camér les caméras éent là par hasard ils
sont passés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
ils étaient où les SDF là
son re je dire pourquoi j'aime sans
rigol j'aime parce que bravo g et je
suis fier de toi parce que j'aime bien
parce que tu défends tes amis même quand
ils sont dans des
sitandand ce tu fais amis c'est pas mes
amis ce ne sont absolument pas mes amis
parc tout ce que tu fais pour eux
franchement Gill c'est une vidéo pour
les sansabriis pour les précaires pour
ceux qui dorment dans la rue et fait ils
sont dans une vidéo invisibilisé c'estàd
qu'en fait on les méprise tellement
qu'ils sont même pas au milieu de ces
gens-l non ils voulaiit pas diffuser les
photos ils ont demandé les autorisations
c'est un double barnome où ils sont en
ce moment merci àpe merci à Pope sur
Twitter leur com est tellement réussi
que tu es obligé de ramen mais al
raconter tout un tas de
trucs c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de pas de
alorsils sont censés les défendre derni
dernier dernier intervenant Daniel Mor
tu dire un truc moi j'ai la photo
d'avance c'est ils nous ont oui mais non
c'est pas ça c'est ce que j'ai
dit moi je n'en peux plus regarde c'est
un mensonge dès le début ils nous disent
qu'ils vont dormir une nuit il y a un
autreé qui se fait filmer en expliquant
comment il va dormir et on les voit 5
minutes après à la brasserie c'est des
mensonges le message est bon mais on n
peut plus regardez ou
cadera c'était bien de
parler
c'éit ouais
çae tu dois mettre un coup sec sous le
palais les d recent
okésite pas je t'exque mais quand c'est
comme ça nésite pas tu fais une petite
pause pas compris
excuse fa combien
tempion
as pas encore compris
fonctionnementémission Michel explii tu
ferme ta gueule quand
[Applaudissements]
par les phrases courtes intelligi voilà
prends des
courophonie et les avis tranchés et
voilà merci jeanmich le sondage qui va
encore donner raison à Gill ver j'en
suis sûr voilà Gill verd toujours
monsieur non mais sans déconnaiss c'est
sur la tête de ma mère c'est casparov le
mec éche sur éche dramatique on voit
l'argent qu'ils ont ils ont foutu enfin
pas foutu en l'air mais qu'on a dépensé
pour le covid de dire en 2024 en France
il y a encore des gens qui sont dans la
rue c'est pas de la déie c'est quand
même dramatique il y a des casernes il y
a des truc pour faire g c'est quand même
dramatique ce qui se passe quand même la
le sondage pour que VO 330000 30000
personnes il est meilleur en chiffre qu'
opinion allez merci on va passer Aubat
jour par même pas